dans la petite ville de rennes losc la
vie est plutôt cool les filles en
vacances ça fait n'importe quoi c'est
leur première soirée loin de chez elles
elles n'ont plus peur de rien elles vont
y aller à fond à fond bien profond tu es
en train de faire un doigt hamon embrayé
il y a un prix à payer
je suis inquiet pour bruno propre oui ce
qu'il est on n'a pas de nouvelles depuis
une semaine je viens voir ton frère vous
êtes fait d'allier les deux non ben il
s'étire et je crois que c'est haram
stead ou alors à hammersmith ya pas un
bled qui s'appelle appsteur smith non on
dirait un à ce degré bar ya des traces
de crocs j'ai passé ma vie à chasser les
loups-garous hilti ils mangent les airs
jeu dans les reins toinon gia là je sais
pas si on a prévenu mais ce soir c'est
ton sur deux chansons parce que ma
mission c'est d'offrir à la plus jolie
des filles la plus belle des luttes sa
vie
les soit de donner un conseil nous
gardons éloigne poids de cette fille je
voulais te demander si ce que j'ai envie
de sortir avec moi
luttant vitalic et tu seras à son goût
reste aux suivants de la langue de se
monter en pression
étais tu plais à jouir tue encore 24
heures pour tremper ton d'esprit
on va être obligé de coucher ensemble
plongeant du lourd toutes les bourses
un bolide ans
jean françois truffaut leurs péchés
spahic c'est quoi ça c'est à cause des
plumes qui sous hyper douce